clide eustache brinio pour le groupe est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
cheikh collègues dimanche 23 janvier m6
diffusait un reportage sur les dangers
de l'islam radical au cours duquel de
nombreux français ont dû découvrir avec
effroi la réalité de ce qui se passe sur
notre victoire depuis la journaliste
ophélie meunier le juriste amine el bahi
auxquelles nous apportons bien
évidemment tout notre soutien doit être
placée sous protection sous ne suit à de
nombreuses menaces dont ils sont
victimes
en france 35 personnes seraient sous
protection pour des propos jugés
certains pour certains hostiles à
l'islam madame la ministre trouvez vous
normal qu'il va vivre cachés ou protéger
lorsqu on dénonce une idéologie
mortifère qui n'a pas sa place dans
notre pays ou faut-il se taire sur
certains sujets pour vivre tranquille
qu'avez-vous fait concrètement depuis
cinq ans pour faire taire ces pressions
qu'avez-vous fait concrètement pour
dénoncer et lutter contre l'islamisme
contre l'entrisme des frères musulmans
qui continuent à mettre en place leur
projet inlassablement inexorablement sur
notre territoire
on vous répondra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'abord je voudrais si vous me
le permettez commencé par saluer votre
engagement sur ces sujets parce que vous
avez été très impliquée à nos côtés
quand nous avons ensemble voter la loi
confortant les principes de la
république et je crois que nous avons
partagé à la fois ce constat mais aussi
l'objectif est l'urgence de lutter
contre la menace islamiste dans notre
pays et cette loi qui a été enrichie et
voter ici au sénat avec vous avec les
sénateurs elle a permis justement de
nous doter d'un certain nombre d'outils
plus pratique plus utile plus concret et
cela répond madame la sénatrice à votre
question sur qu'avez vous fait eh bien
nous avons pris cette fois nous avons
pris cette fois qui n'existait pas
auparavant
dans la droite ligne du discours des
mureaux du président la république
emmanuel macron qui a décidé enfin de
nommer la menace le séparatisme et de
dire la réalité de ce que nous visions
en france cette loi nous a permis de
nous doter de ce contrat d'engagement
républicains notamment que j'évoquais a
précédemment mais également de renforcer
les menaces la protection face aux
menaces qui peuvent exister notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux nous étions il
ya à peine quelques semaines avec le
premier ministre et le garde des sceaux
chez pharos et au parquet buts contre la
haine en ligne qui protège et qui met en
oeuvre les dispositifs de la loi
confortant les principes de la
république vous voyez le gouvernement
agit nous faisons fermer les
établissements qui représente une menace
nous le faisons grâce à l'action des
cuirs et nous faisons grâce à la loi qui
a été renforcée et je vous remercie
encore pour cela warm up
madame la ministre excusez moi mais
encore des mots toujours des mots est
toujours votre ambiguïté le en novembre
2019 le sénat mettez en place une
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste et pour la
première fois le 24 janvier 2020 comme
par hasard juste après le président de
la république parlait enfin de
séparatisme le sénat a voulu vous tendre
la main plusieurs fois par des
amendements que certains d'entre vous
qualifie hypocritement d'amendements
textile l'interdiction de signes
ostentatoires lors d accompagnement
scolaire tout comme les compétitions
sportives encore récemment
l'interdiction du burkina vous avez
toujours renoncer vous avez toujours
refusé en préférant subir les pressions
de minorités agité par peur de les
combattre par l'arche par lâcheté et
para commandement que ge apparente à du
clientélisme
pendant ce temps là la base arrière des
frères des frères musulmans lissage de
château chinon et de saint-denis
participerait à la formation des imams
dans le cadre du conseil national des
imams alors madame la ministre les
français en ont assez des paroles ils
veulent des actes ils veulent des
preuves et vous ne nous les données pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]